-I'm hot for both of them.
-That's so hot.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Strums ]
-There was a time, you know,
back when...
I was the one on magazines.
He was nobody.
He couldn't believe
he was even talking to me.
He said that to me.
"You're Birdie Jay
on billboards.
I can't believe
I'm talking to you."
He was this...little thing
in my hand.
-[ Laughs ]
-I preferred that.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Kate Hudson.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That was a clip
from "Glass Onion:
A Knives Out Mystery."
And I mean this sincerely --
as we talk about family,
where a lot of us are
about to spend the holidays
with our families --
it is so nice to have a movie
that, certainly,
with the first one,
we all watched it together
and this is the same thing.
-Oh, yeah.
-It's a really funny movie.
It's a whodunit.
-Yeah.
-And it's a wonderful cast.
-Yeah, and, honestly,
it's hilarious.
It's also like you're in Greece,
you know,
and the backdrop of this movie
is just so yummy
and it's a blast.
I mean, I have to say,
the first time I saw it was
with the Toronto Film Festival
audience of 1,500 people
and I was really nervous.
But the second
the movie started,
that audience was just
uproariously laughing,
totally with it,
totally engaged.
And, I mean, it doesn't happen
very often,
so, I feel really lucky
to be in it.
-Credit to Rian Johnson,
who's really done
-Oh, he's incredible.
-something special here.
A really cool thing that he did
with the first movie and he's
doing again -- put together
this really eclectic cast
-Yeah.
-of really fun people.
One thing that was very cool
for me,
because I'm this big a fan
of hers as I am of yours --
-[ Laughs ]
-Kathryn Hahn.
-Yes!
-Here you are. Kathryn Hahn.
And you guys, of course,
worked together
in "How to Lose a Guy
in 10 Days"
-We did. Look, we're babies!
-20 years ago!
[ Cheering and applause ]
20 years ago.
We're little babies.
I was so --
[ Posh accent ] Excuse me
while I fix my earring.
[ Laughter ]
This thing.
Oh, this little thing
that I don't own.
-There's a lot -- Yeah.
-See?
Is it on? Is it on?
-It's on. Yeah.
-It'll fall again.
It's fine.
I like a prop.
-I mean, look,
I think the important thing is,
if it falls,
you have to know
that's legally ours.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, perfect.
But, Kathryn, honestly,
like when we met,
we auditioned together.
I auditioned her for the movie
and we were
auditioning best friends,
and I was in the room
and she came in
and she was
so [bleep] funny like.
There's nobody funnier
than Kathryn Hahn.
And her phone rang in --
like her flip phone,
at the time,
rang in the audition.
She was like -- "Oh, my God!
I have to get it!"
-[ Laughs ]
-And she was like --
took the phone call
in the middle of the audition
and we all kind of looked
at each other like,
"I mean, yeah,"
and it was her first movie.
So, we like --
I can't even tell you --
we just became so close.
And then as life goes,
like she lives east of the 405.
I'm west of the 405.
And, in L.A. terms, that's like
you'll never see each other
again, you know?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Like it's like maybe
that's kind of like way uptown
and way downtown in New York.
-Yeah, I think that's --
It's more like here
and Brooklyn, yeah.
-Right.
-When you have friends
who move to Brooklyn,
you're like, "Well...
-Yeah, "Goodbye."
-I loved our time together."
[ Laughter ]
-That's me and Kathryn.
-Yeah.
-And so, now, here we are,
like 20 years later and --
-Are you ever jealous
of the fact
that her first movie
is a classic
and your first movie, you won't
even say the title of out loud?
[ Laughter ]
-Ohhh, yes.
That's so funny.
-Also, this movie, I should say,
for everybody who's looking
forward to seeing it,
there's a lot of cameos
that are very exciting.
-Oh, so many fun cameos.
-Did they keep that a secret
from you guys
-Yeah. Well...
-until the day? Well, I mean,
as much as they could, right?
-I knew of them,
but then I kind of forgot them
because when, you know,
a year goes by
and then you see the movie
and you're like, "Oh, yeah."
And there's one cameo,
in particular, we can't say.
That was my favorite.
-That's pretty exciting,
to have a cameo so good
that you can't say it on TV.
-I know.
-Really?
-It's a good one.
-And that's really great.
-It's my favorite one.
-Alright. Well, I think
everybody's going to have
a reason to watch when it's out.
-That's right.
-Christmas season,
anytime a movie can come out,
you can watch
with your whole family
in Christmas season,
you've given a gift
to the world.
-That's right.
-Thank you
-Thank you.
-and your entire cast and Rian
and thanks so much
for being here.
-I know, Seth.
-It's always just a joy
to see you.
-So good to see you.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Kate Hudson.
"Glass Onion:
A Knives Out Mystery" premieres
on Netflix December 23rd.
We'll be right back
with Angie Rito
and Scott Tacinelli.